hello
we're glad you've joined us for this
live webinar how multiplexed imaging
reveals key insights into the tumor
micro environment to inform treatment
and
improve outcomes today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots
the leading scientific social networking
website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
science collaboration and learning
it is brought to you by sativa sativa is
a global provider of technologies and
services that advance and accelerate the
development and manufacture of
therapeutics
formerly part of ge healthcare life
sciences they have a rich heritage
tracing back hundreds of years and a
fresh beginning since
two thousand for more information on our
sponsor
you can click on the sponsor logo on the
left side of your screen
or visit sativallifesciences.com
now let's get started you can pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left of your
screen
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process of obtaining your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our host of
today's webinar
paul goodwin president of the
histochemical society and science
director of sativa
for complete biographies on all our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
welcome paul the floor is yours
christy thank you very much for your
introduction i'm
looking forward to telling you about our
multiplex imaging and the role and
understanding the tissue micro
environment
uh i'm paul goodwin as christie
introduced um
i'll be talking about the resurgence of
multiple immunohistochemistry
and a bit of the history of the field
i'll be followed by dr fiona
gente who we talked who is a researcher
and technical manager
in biosciences at the ge research center
should be telling us about cell dive
imaging a decade of research validation
and translation
and then we'll be followed by prachip
ghetto
is a diagnostic segment leader and
marketing leader for cell analysis
within saltiva
and she'll be talking to us about the
cell dive imaging advancing cancer
research and care
i'd like to start us off by uh looking
at the history and
resurgence of multiplex
immunohistochemistry and to me the story
starts with cancer
if you think of cancer and i know for a
long time i was locked in my career
thinking of cancer is a disease
of genetics in the cell cycle but that's
part of the story so
as cells are exposed to the environment
they have a genetic history in the age
of the individual
you accumulate a series of mitotic uh
sorry the series of genetic defects in
the cells
this leads to loss of control of mitosis
which then means that checkpoints the
proof reading of the
genome gets skipped which leads to more
genetic instability which leads to more
mutations which leads to more skipping
etc
but that's only part of the story that
leads to unchecked cell growth the other
part of cancer
is a loss of identity so cells live
within an environment
um and they they understand who they are
and what they are what they're supposed
to be doing because of the environment
around them
if they lose their ability to sense that
environment and
interact with that with other cells in
that environment
again because of the cells themselves
their environment or the age
they then lose their identity and they
don't think they no longer belong where
they are
and so they'll go walk about the we call
that um
metastasis and those cells will go and
try to find a new environment where they
feel more at home
which can lead to more disruption of
their sensing of the environment
which leads to more mito metastasis etc
so if we want to understand
immuno-oncology or the interaction of
the immune system
and cancer we have to realize that
cancer is not just a genetic disease
there also is a wide and meaningful
dynamic range for many structures and
objects
that are important for understanding the
interaction of not only the
genetic defects within the cells but
also their interaction
the environment so it's not enough to
know that how many cells i have per area
i also may need to know the intensity
or the mass of staining per area
there are also many many different
components within the tissue within the
cells i need to understand
and it also is very important by the
anatomical context the sense of place
is really critical to understanding
what's going on in the tumor and just
knowing what cells are there
through looking at transcriptomics or
binding and grinding and
measuring protein concentrations is
insufficient to fully understand the
tumor
so if i want to make a system that will
allow me to study that complex micro
environment
i need a system that's both sensitive
that is it has a
very high signal to noise ratio it's
specific
that is i can identify the the specific
signals i'm interested in measuring
and dissociate them from the background
and from non
non-specific interactions they need to
have a dynamic range
one and zero is not sufficient i need a
range
and that range needs to be linear so i
can trust it
i also need to look at many many factors
in the same sample
and serial sectioning is usually
insufficient because of the size of the
cells that we're looking at and the size
of the structures we're trying to
identify
as i said the anatomical context is
essential
they have possible we'd love to be able
to do this non-destructively
to leave open the opportunity for coming
back and studying
either the sequence or or rna
transcripts within the sample i'm
looking at
this is what i was talking about earlier
the challenges of studying immuno
oncology
and this is a cartoon by drew but we can
see here within the sample this is
supposed to represent a microscope
field of view and maybe i have a blood
vessel here in red
uh to the right of that i have a large
green cell there's our tumor cell
if you notice that a little brown cells
next to that those maybe represent
immune cells which are a fraction of the
size of the cancer cell
in many cases there are also other
things in the environment
stromal cells or cells that describe
just the structure
of the tissue in which the cell the
tumor lives
there also are proteins and other
microstructures
that all interact with the tumor cell to
define this environment
and then go about defining this exact
tumor
why want to better understand it so how
do biologists understand this kind of
environment today
historically the microscope was invented
in 17th century and we had the ability
to start looking at things that were
smaller than we could see with our naked
eye
but if you just look at a piece of
tissue and so the left hand side here we
see
a section of mouse lung that is
just thinly sliced and put on the micro
microscope slide you see it's very
difficult to see any structure
to see any cells of that but fortunately
the early microscopists were also very
much
involved with the textile industry so
the first things they did was they took
textile dyes things that they would use
to stain
fabric blue or pink and they applied
those to the microscope slide and
suddenly structure became apparent
and so in the slide on the right we can
see the pink
which is stained with eosin and purple
dots which are the nuclei of the cells
that stay in the nucleus that that
science is called histochemistry
we can go further beyond the
histochemistry and here we have again a
piece of a mouse lung uh generally
generously provided to us by dr
charles freebur at the university of
washington
so we have general histochemical
standing on the left but
with koontz in 1945 and years later
developed the ability to look for very
specific molecules
within that tissue so we see brown
staining here with a
so-called dab reaction in this case
identifying the very specific mole
molecule uh highly highlighted neuron
and so we can get very specific
molecules with immunohistic chemistry
the problem with that kind of
immunohistochemistry is we're limited to
the number of things we can look at at
the same time
so here's a two color it's actually rna
fluorescence in situ hybridization
but you can see there's a little there's
a blue labeling in the in the stainless
with the arrow on on some of the arrows
and we also see red staining
with some of the other arrows and the
background of purple
and so you're trying to see pink and
blue and purple all on top of each other
and so that limits our ability to see
staining with chromogenic stain
but if we look on the other side we can
see with fluorescence we can see
more colors so here we have on the right
we have a wrap
eyelets in the pancreas
in blue we see the nuclei of these cells
and then we see staining in red
which is glucagon in the alpha cells
that surround
the eyelid and then we see staining in
green
which is against insulin which
identifies the beta cells within the
eyelid
and if we look at these colors
independently we can see
that it's very easy for us to dissociate
and to understand where the nuclei are
where the glucagon standing cells are
and with the insulin staining cells
but sometimes this few colors here here
we have three labels
sometimes that's not enough and you can
see if we want to understand the complex
environment
of a tumor that we need much more than
three stains
and so over the years a number of
techniques have been developed
from chromogenic and you know
histochemistry and fluorescence
immunistic chemistry which we just saw
to multi-spectral imaging to spectral
mixing
serial multiplexing and many other
techniques
um and today we're going to look at one
of these in depth called serial
multiplexing
and without going to turn the mic over
to dr fiona genti
hi hi everybody this is best the only
guinty uh thanks paul for the
great introduction and the history of
immunohistochemistry and a nice lead
into
the work that i'm about to present uh
for the next 30 minutes or so
on what we've done over the last uh 10
over over 10 years actually
at the ge global research center in miss
kiuna in new york
so i'm going to uh just give you sort of
a step back in history but also
start with where we are today in terms
of spatial
cell biology and uh the sort of
importance that sort of bear in mind
some of you are new to this some of
some of you are are studying this for
some time now but
um really spatial cell biology is
opening up new insights into health and
disease
as regards looking at diseases at a
single cell level really allows us to
understand how and why disease
uh progress and gives us new insights
into heterogeneity
into the types of cell types involved
the immune cells
the different functionalities of those
cells and the microenvironment and the
stroma
around those cells and and potentially
the crosstalk between those two
uh environments and so with that with
that new level of understanding by
understanding where the cells are
located how they're interacting with
each other
we can begin to now chip away at
understanding disease mechanisms
um immune response facial cell
interactions and hopefully that leads us
towards
new ways to diagnose uh disease in the
future
now when we started this work um over 10
years ago
we really started with a blank slate and
at the time thought really deeply about
why we wanted to go into
um pathology and we as ge is a
destroyed history and in medical imaging
looked at what we had done
in radiology and that transition from um
analog
to digital in radiology and saw
really an opportunity in the pathology
space for
making that transition to to digitize
images and potential value of that and
there were other companies working at
that at the time but we saw the
key opportunities around speed um
usability for the
for the pathologist and then the content
within the image
what else other than the h e features
that are so
um close to the to the pathologist
workflow today
how could we um expand that information
uh to be more protein
focused and cellular focused so we
started this brand new program back in
2006
many of us most of us in fact had never
worked in pathology or oncology before
but in a sense that was a good way to
start because we all
came at the problem with the within
unique mindset and how we might solve
this problem but this also precipitated
our interactions with academia pharma
and
clinical end users because we knew from
them that
we would need to know exactly what their
workflows are what their problems were
today
and how we could solve together with
them so
over the next 20 minutes or so i'll tell
you more about how we
um went through that path but just to
sort of shortcut it to the end
you know we fast forward uh you know 10
years and we
you know in that time we transitioned we
developed our workflows we optimized
them we transferred it to
clarion and neogenomics as the
multiomics
technology and that was offered as a
service and then
uh two years ago we started working more
closely with our
saitiva um collaborate um
partners rather and uh formerly
key life sciences and then allowed us to
deploy the system out to prototype of
prototypes out to our collaborators
and this really gave us the hands-on and
knowledge that we needed
to gather to to proceed um to what is
now today the commercial launch of zelda
which we're all very proud of
so just to get into the to the details
and
then we can talk a little bit more about
the collaborations but essentially this
is a
initiative staining method we use
immunofluorescence
we developed a method by which we could
do an antigen retrieval
one time at the beginning of the process
a lot of work went into the imaging
and i'll talk a bit about that as well
but knowing you know these
samples because we're in fluorescence
imaging we have background so we had to
consider that that autofluorescence
signal and we imaged the sample after
staining
uh we de-stain it and then we do a cycle
of 30 to 40 cycles or 60-plus
biomarkers and that gives us this very
deep
and you can see as i'm going through the
slides here
this very rich data set which um
can then lead you into a process by
which you can analyze all of these
biomarkers
at a single cell level and then
spatially because the coordinates for
every cell is conserved
and in each of the in each of the images
that are taken
so then we here we see an example from
our publication that we had it back in
2013 in the pnas where we
show this montage of 43 different
proteins
in colorectal cancer and this was our
first big publication
which we you know worked very hard at
for several years to make sure we had
covered
all the bases and all the um different
aspects of the workflow so that we
weren't just at that point
presenting a set of images we also
presented comparisons to
and some ground truths we worked with
memorial sloan kettering which i'll show
you
shortly and then devise methods by which
the images could be registered the
autofluorescent subtracted
and then um some cells could be
segmented
and then we could quantify it at a
single biomarker level
so this whole workflow you know took
several years really to figure out and
develop into a
highly automated workflow where images
could be processed as they were being
collected which is our
sort of standard today as the images are
being
um as the samples are being imaged they
are automatically being registered
autoforest and subtracted and um
[Music]
they are you know it's something that's
done while you're imaging rather than
waiting to the end
of the process so then when you're
finished your whole experiment you have
a registered
af removed a authorized removed set of
images for the number of biomarkers that
you've studied
and so with that you know we had the
next challenge was really the
reducing these millions of data points
because as you know in one field of view
you have perhaps 3 000
cells depending on the cancer type now
scale that to
50 100 patients if you're working with
tmas or if you're working with whole
tissue sections
uh you now are in a sphere of millions
and
and even close to a billion data points
and depending on how many biomarkers so
we developed
a lot of different workflows which we've
published on over the years on
looking at you know biomarker
correlations um
assuming you know certain biomarkers
should be co-expressed then we should
see these in these types of correlation
plots
that we generate and the darker the the
circle here being the stronger the
association between those markers
we developed some nice workflows for
clustering different types of
cells depending on their biomarker
expression and then working with our
collaborators we translated all of that
workflow
to real life examples and in this
example i'll talk about again later in
dr carcinoma
in situ you can see where we look at
both the lesion area
which is uh colored in brown it's a very
homogeneous
group of cells as opposed to the patient
below it which is more heterogeneous
there's more
colors present and you also see
interestingly in this particular
patients the same sample a lot of immune
cells
around the outside of the lesion and on
the patient below that less
immune cell so we're actually doing a
larger study on this
at the moment with indiana university
so then with that you know you really
open up the door once you've got your
workflows down
you're confident about the
reproducibility uh you have the antibody
validation which is another huge
part of what we we've done over the last
10 years you can really start
to think about where um
single cell analysis makes sense and we
have done studies in immuno phenotyping
we've looked at the single signaling
pathway heterogeneity this is also part
of the pnaf paper
and then we've also more recently
started working in neurology
and applying the same workflows
now with all of that of course we have
to consider
the the hardware itself and so a key key
part of what we've done
over the last um 10 years is really uh
ensuring that
the quality of the images is consistent
there's a calibration
workflow that we put in place to ensure
that the
um systems are can be compared to each
other the data output can be
compared to each other and uh this was
carried forward uh over the last 10
years when we
implemented the workflow at neogenomics
these calibrations were also put in
place
and so it's just been a hallmark of of
our workflow
and ensures really the quality of the
data um
at the at the end of a study and allows
it to be comparable
to to other subsequent data sets in the
future
now just so that we can um sort of
not uh certainly take credit for all of
the work that we did we our team is a
multi-disciplinary team we we're really
you know as an amazing team to work with
over the last decade we're we're
comprised of biologists and chemists and
engineers and computer vision scientists
and statisticians and
physicists and and you name it um but
we you know the beauty of this team was
that we were able to work
closely with uh these collaborators um
and i'm just going to mention a few
today um but
i'll uh briefly talk about what we did
with each of them and how we learned
from them we listened to them we learned
from them and then how in turn we
deployed uh those workflows into into
what is cell dive today so i'll talk a
little bit about
memorial zone kettering cancer center
fantastic
collaborators eli lilly pharmaceutical
company
and then our various nih programs which
we
um are awards uh that we we achieved in
collaboration with with several
different collaborators across the u.s
and internationally as well
so really uh i'll start with memorial
sloan kettering
cancer center or mskcc um
we really worked with them from day one
um on
back in in 2006 we were really learning
from scratch
about the pathology space and you know
spent many days down in their pathology
the department watching them watching
the pathologists
watching the workflows understanding
what could be changed and
what could not be changed within the uh
standard
and histochemistry workflow um a few key
things
that we learned during this time and we
started with breast cancer because that
was
one uh area where we you know there were
there were well
uh documented well uh reported markers
eastern receptors
are two staining that have you know are
widely used in diagnosis today so that
gave us our ground truth
on which we started to compare a lot of
our
assays and our assay performance um
we also then once we had some confidence
in and the performance of our antibodies
in our workflows
we then started to get more complicated
and they had some very nice
rna expression data sets uh that we
that they wanted to compare our our
workflows to so that's sort of another
important point in any new technology
for those of you are
already working in this type of field is
you know comparing back to the
previous data or the earlier data and
and proving that either you get the same
results
or equivocal or or new finding is
but certainly step one is to prove that
you compare
to what's been done before an
alternative method
and another key learning from this
period was in working with the
pathologist there
was the need for a something that was
familiar to them so this
virtual h e we we developed so we
converted the
grayscale images to uh what looks like
an h e and you can see that here in the
uh
in the uh in the in the figure shown on
the right that pink
image is created from that brown
grayscale
image um so those are the two sort of
key things of many many learnings as
well but
just that brown truth and and the
reference
uh image that was familiarity to to the
pathologist was very important
and then once we you know we've worked
with msk for for a few years at that
point then as i said we started to get
more complex and there they um
proposed that we do an rna expression
uh comparison study where we uh they
already knew
the results they knew in this case the
correlation with ftg uptake
and they wanted to prove that we could
find the same correlation and in fact we
did
and um we also showed um not
surprisingly and you can see in these
smaller images from the publication
uh with dr ingle mellinghoff and these
are overlaid pie charts or clusters of
cells and the more color
they're more black color so here you see
yellow
more yellow that's more homogeneous is
more of that type of cluster cluster
eight
and whereas on the figure on the left we
see much more heterogeneity
more colors in each of the pie charts
and so this was really the sort of the
start of our work and
of others in looking and thinking about
heterogeneizy and how that
relates to two outcomes
now in parallel with that we also knew
that we needed to understand the
pharmaceutical workflow and here we
worked with eli lilly
again for about five years in fact we
worked with them on cell lines
pre-clinical samples
clinical samples from multiple sites
they're looking at that cross-site
variability and then also looking at
larger retrospective cohorts with
recurrence and outcome data so that gave
us
a new um understanding of data size
big data comparisons with across groups
stratification and we developed all of
our
statistical workflows in in r which are
still used today
and we share readily with our
collaborators but here we also looked at
antibody validation this was of course a
very
key theme that carried all the way
through all of our collaborations
and having a really well characterized
workflow which i'll
talk about in the next slide another
thing that we
learned with eli lilly is you know as we
went from you know in our early days we
were just working on one microscope
and now we need groove to go to multiple
microscopes so we set up a lab with 10
microscopes and they're inlaid the
challenge for calibration
for cross comparison of data
slot quality control slides controlled
slides
um etc study design and so we really uh
for
a few years with eli lilly and with our
other collaborators really focused on
our statistical workflows
our normalization and again that sort of
led to where we are today in terms of
when we publish papers we always
describe our workflow and uh and you
know share our experiences on that um
on that sort of scaling from one
microscope to multiple microscopes and
here on the right is just some of the
work that we
published with eli lilly that they were
very interested in
blood vessel development and we looked
at
many different markers related to early
stage blood vessel maturation
late stage blood vessel maturation and
the interaction with the immuno
profiling
um we really as i said focus on antibody
validation workflow and this is just
where i want to
emphasize for just just a moment that we
um
you know worked out this uh uh
sort of very rigorous uh workflow which
we still use
today um at the time when we started to
work with eli lilly dr jeremy graf who
we worked with at the time
was extremely helpful and and rigorous
with us
in terms of advising of how best what
they would need from a pharma
direct perspective and this certainly
maps to every other collaborator
that we worked with since and and we
have hundreds of antibodies that we've
uh commercial antibodies that we've
validated
to this point where we do a direct
conjugation so we directly label those
antibodies with
with our dyes size binding dyes or
electrodyes
and that in turn allows you to do this
high level of multiplexing so we do a
primary secondary
usually in the first round and then
follow that with
direct conjugates for how many and
however many rounds
are needed we also test the number of
dyes
to protein ratio we keep that consistent
we always
test from batch to batch variability so
a lot of really important
um um consistencies that are important
for your you know follow
repeating of your study and uh and those
are implemented in the protocols that
are
are are shared today both in our
publications and as part of the cell
dive
package um so now i'll talk a little bit
um for the next
five minutes or so on a few different uh
our nih programs and this was really you
know a fantastic opportunity back in
2008 this was really
you know very very early days for single
cell analysis
and we were able to you know with the
nih you were
establishing a single cell analysis
program at the time
this gave you know really a huge head
start to the field
so we're always you know very thankful
to the nih for for that and then our
collaborators that we worked with at the
time
in particular we started with vanderbilt
university and we also work with suny
albany
and uh dr bob coffey and his team we
we conducted work on single cell
analysis in colon cancer development
uh with that you know you sort of do you
either are many benefits to
to these types of relationships you
understand better what they need from a
research perspective in this case we
needed very precise
single cell segmentation because the
cells that we were looking at in colon
are very varied in their in their shape
and their size
and and no cell you do not want to leave
any cell
out of your analysis and this group were
very early adopter of the cell dive
prototype and they've been
using it ever since giving us great
feedback and then more recently
they were one of the five awardees of
the human tumor atlas
and so that was quite exciting to see
that progress you know from beginning to
where they are today
um in the last five years then um i've
also been pi
on um uh this work with indiana
university
and uh with dr sunil badzie and dr
yester polar
and here we're looking at again taking
all of the the learnings that i've
explained earlier around
um heterogeneity and clustering data
analysis
and looking at cellular heterogeneity of
dcis
lesions of structural carcinoma in situ
at the earliest stage
of breast cancer pre-invasive and here
we're looking at
20 to 30 different markers related to
both cell signaling as well as immune
response
we're looking at different ethnicities
we're comparing
across these different groups the
expression of these proteins
and how they differ in terms of outcome
we're right in the middle of analyzing
our outcome data at the moment and
that should be concluded this summer but
seeing very marked differences from
patient to patient
and immune response response so i think
this data that's going to be
you know quite exciting once we're
finished and we're publishing of course
all this work
another a very more software focused
project that we we've been working with
upit
for for many years and
here we have been working with lance
taylor and
and um chocolation about zabata and
uh in this case we have a had a very uh
sort of
a different type of approach here we we
developed heterogeneity algorithms which
are actually available on
what we call the thrive website and and
this is related to the
acronyms related to tumor heterogeneity
and
um here we look at heterogeneity spatial
heterogeneity we continue some of our
work in colorectal cancer we're able to
carry some of these data sets through
we have um shown in this in this
web-based
analysis that we can both conduct very
simple
um a single cell analysis as well as
the metrics for quantifying
heterogeneity and both these
uh work are published and and we
continue to have a very good
relationship
with a university of pittsburgh and that
team
now we of course mostly focused our work
around oncology to begin with
um and for still today but we did do
some very interesting work and this work
is led by dan meyer
dr dan meyer at the ge research center
and here he's extended cell dive
workflow to neuroscience
and taking many of the same concepts but
of course neurology is a very different
beast to oncology but looking at
molecular diversity
cellular interactions and
microenvironmental factors
in brain and the underlying mechanisms
of neurodegeneration
and he has also been the recipient of
several
awards from the nih working with ucsf
and mount sinai and boston university
and so we've been working for the last
couple of years and very large cohorts
that um have been provided by each of
these sites and looking at many of these
questions that
are very sort of carried through you
know from disease to disease
um heterogeneity cells of cells and
interaction
is just now you know a very common theme
no matter
what type of disease state you're uh
you're working on
um and most recently uh this has been a
very exciting
new uh area for us we're working with
the hub map the nih
the part of the nih commons fund and
here we're looking with a
large consortium we in our case we're
looking at healthy tissue we're looking
at
multi-scale 3d image analytics this is
led by
my colleague joseph and and and
anupsud and here again we're working
with university of pittsburgh in the
dermatology department
and we're combining uh the multiplex
imaging serial multiflex imaging of skin
samples
together with micro ct and
seeing you know how we can combine sort
of a 3d reconstruction of these
multiplexed images
together with a a validated if you like
3d imaging method microct and i think
you know we're looking at is you know
once we've got that 3d
reconstruction that analysis done how do
look at changes
as a function of aging and uv exposure
look at changes in
immune cells for example over time or in
relation to uv damaged
markers of dna damage um so this work is
just in its first year and
it's an exciting group to be part of
there's a lot of
other cell atlas efforts going on across
the u.s and around the world at the
moment
and um you know i think it's sort of
we're all learning together as well as
you know recognizing that there are many
commonalities across
both disease type organ and tissue
so just to my last slide um before i
transition over to to perachy but
um you know we're sort of closed out
here on uh you know many years on
foundation of research of development of
ideas and concepts that we
implemented into software and workflows
and
uh 2014 was was a landmark for us
because we
at that point had had confidence in the
standardization of our workflow we had
you know scaled the workflow the data
analytics the software
and so we worked them closely with
clarion um
to transition all of those workflows to
their
uh service lab and
their own regulated environment in 2014
and they then
you know took it from there if you like
and they developed a
clinical laboratory improvement
amendment clear
assay for hodgkin lymphoma um
to publish that work showed that the
workflow
and multiplexing workflow single cell
multiplexing workflow
compared um extremely well with the
pathologist review of a single slide
analysis of hodgkin lymphoma
we also subsequent to that as i said
earlier we started to do
prototype deployment and we started with
sunnybrook
health sciences center toronto and
vanderbilt
etc and they all just really provided us
with critical user needs
uh calibration automation and just
troubleshooting in general
and then 2017 2018 we started to
expand that out to other expert uh
collaboration sites
and now we're here today in 2020 and uh
commercializing
uh the platform uh together with uh
sativa
and so i just wanna close on on this
slide just to sort of remind
you of you know how we and we at the
beginning did not
know the space we did not fully
understand the space with scientists and
engineers but we
listened we learned we developed robust
protocols
we took all our feedback and turned it
into a
a workflow that was relevant and we
focused on disease-specific
applications to show the utility of what
we were doing and why
and we just tried along the way publish
and continuously approve
improve our workflow so that they stayed
current with the times
and stayed relevant um and so with that
i'm happy to
transfer over to uh karachi baguetto
and she'll tell you more about the cell
dive imaging workflow
hi everybody i'm practical thank you
fiona for walking us through
all of the development that went into
the cell dive multiplex
imaging solution which is what i will be
talking about for the next 10 minutes or
so
so as we heard from paul we've seen a
resurgence in multiplex
imaging the real driver for that is the
advent of
immuno oncology and therapies that
harness
a patient's immune system to fight
cancer
the imaging technologies we had in the
past do not provide
rich enough data to help us guide
these therapies for patients to better
outcomes but also to give us the
information we need
about the immune system of patients to
develop
better therapies in the future
suppressive imaging
as you see in the traditional h e
in this case this is the virtual h e as
fiona described
gives us some very rough information
first and most important
is this tissue cancerous or not in case
of some information about the types and
number of cells
in the tumor and around the tumor but
what we really need
is the rich information that multiplex
imaging brings to diagnoses
such as what cell types are present what
is their biomarker expression profile
what's the nature and the extent of
vascularization within the tumor micro
environment
what kind of cells are in the tumor and
around the tumor
and what are the specific immune cells
within the tumor this is the kind of
information that we need
to really harness the power of the
immune system
for therapies in cancer
so the top of this slide you see what is
a traditional
imaging workflow this happens to be a
bright field imaging workflow
which is typically limited to one or two
biomarkers per slide
and so what that compels the researcher
to do as you can see here
is to make serial sections and slides of
this one
precious piece of tissue since you can
only stain and visualize
at best two and usually one biomarker
per tissue slide
what multiplex imaging and specifically
cell guys multiplex imaging
brings to the table is the ability to
visualize 60 plus proteins
from the same tissue slice and leaving
it
intact for other investigations
so as fiona described it took many many
years
to refine both the staining and the
imaging for this particular technology
and we're pleased to talk you through a
little bit about
what it is and what is now available so
we introduce here
cell dive multiplex imaging solution
which is a completely
customizable multiplex solutions that
precisely maps up to more than 60
biomarkers
from just one tissue section with
resolution at a single cell level
when we say customizable what do we mean
you choose the assay panels you choose
which fire markers and how many
you would like to visualize all of the
work that you heard
fiona describe in refining this
technology
comes together to bring extreme
precision
to all of the imaging so we take
precision engineered hardware innovative
acquisition software
to give you precise imaging and
downstream
the capability to do single cell
analysis and as you know by now
we've spent many many years refining all
of these technologies
so we can bring
reproducible reliable results
so what are the components of the cell
dive multiplex imaging system
he taken all of the innovation in the
workflow
which fiona described and i will
describe a little bit later
and the acquisition software together
with
a vast list of validated commercially
available antibodies
and packaged them into a license the
second component
is the imager which i'll discuss in
detail later
and the third piece is analysis software
we chosen to partner with indica labs
and their software platform halo and
i'll talk a little bit in detail about
why
we think halo is the best choice to
interpret the results from this kind of
imaging
so at a high level the cell dive
multiplexed
imaging solution workflow is displayed
on this slide
in terms of inputs you can input an
entire tissue slide
so the system is capable of handling the
standard
tissue size of a human biopsy you have
the option to choose within that whole
piece of tissue
individual regions of interest you can
also input
a tissue micro array there are five
steps to the imaging and staining rounds
you need the background autofluorescence
imaging
stain the sample image the sample
the system does the image processing and
alignment for you
you inactivate the die and this process
can be repeated
as many times as you need for 60 plus
biomarker visualization downstream then
you would
analyze the data and interpret the
results from your imaging so at a high
level
that's the workflow that's what enables
the imaging of 60 plus biomarkers
biomarker panel design so when we say
completely customizable that's really
what we mean
you choose the biomarkers you choose
which biomarkers
the cell died solution includes a list
of thoughtfully curated
antibodies all of which are commercially
available
there are polyclonals monoclonals mouth
and humans antibodies that relate to
well-studied and understood disease
states and signaling pathways
including the most prevalent modalities
of cancer
and if this list doesn't include
antibodies that
pertain to your area of research there
is
within the software a very detailed
protocol to allow you to characterize
your own antibodies
so we provide you complete flexibility
in terms of panel design
this goes a little bit deeper into the
dye inactivation process that really
allows the
cyclical staining that leaves your
tissue intact
so the tissue is stained with dapi as a
nuclear stain this is what allows the
the image registration of serial images
and then up to four diconjugated
antibodies at one time
the dyes themselves are inactivated to
turn off the dye molecules so the
samples are not damaged
and this is really what allows for the
cyclical nature of this staining
as you saw in some of the work fiona
presented the first patent for this
this serial staining and deactivation
was issued in 2009
it's been significantly refined since
then
so to image the slides that have been
stained with this process
we've created a purpose-built software
suite and really the goal is to make
multiplexing seamless for
the user the software itself tracks
every single slide in the process so
that allows you to do
studies with a large number of slides it
allows you to do
different studies interrupting
each other without having to keep track
of
which particular slide is where in the
workflow
within the software there's an automated
calibration routine
so that allows you to correlate your
data across multiple slides
across multiple studies and across
multiple imagers should that be the case
all of the image processing and
alignment is
automated and refined and this is really
what enables
the downstream single cell analysis
the software is coupled with the imager
the imager is built on
our in-cell platform which were released
in 2001
we are experts in precision engineering
and this system is fast
precise and sensitive we made some
improvements to um
better facilitate tissue imaging so the
system is capable of imaging
in five channels or wavelengths at the
same time
the barcode reader is integrated with
the system and with the software so this
is how you can track your slides
it's compatible with a slide handling
robot so
you can walk away while it does the
imaging the image processing and image
alignment
it has a large maximum imaging area
it can handle very large tissue
with absolutely no issues
the final component of the cell dive
multiplex imaging system is halo image
analysis software and we chose halo
for its ease of use and scalability
the interface is very logical it's very
intuitive and what we really wanted to
do
is to bring the capability to analyze
these images
to people who may not have any
bioinformatics experience
we've worked with halo extensively
during our beta testing period
and we found their responsiveness and
user support to be
world class halo commons in different
modules with different licenses
so you can choose what best suits your
work
so here's just one example of how all of
these come together
all of these components come together to
provide the capability to do true single
cell analysis
so what you see here on the left is the
image of a tonsil tissue
that was part of a 30 marker cell dive
study here we've highlighted five of
those markers and as you progress from
left to right you can see staining
segmentation classification and finally
down to
single cell analysis of cellular
phenotypes
this is just one of many examples of how
the cell dive imaging system in all of
its components
comes together to bring you reliable
reproducible
results none of this
would have been possible without the
expertise
the innovation and the sheer persistence
of the ge research cell dive team
past and present we owe them a huge
thank you without
them we wouldn't be bringing this
capability to the market today
so we'd love to keep in touch with you
if you'd like more information
you can go to saitiva.com forward slash
cell dive
or drop us a note dot die
at sciteva.com
thank you for your time and attention
today and
we'd be happy to take questions
uh
uh
wow
all right thank you for those
presentations we're gonna
move into the q a section
um so we're gonna we have quite a few
questions here
okay so one of the first questions
is both
noise and background are non-specific
signals
um why is one linked to specificity and
the other to sensitivity
um do one of you guys want to take that
question
i think that's a good one for fiona sure
yeah so um
that's a that's a good question so when
we image a sample
and we always take a background imaging
step uh first of all
and because we want to remove the
inherent fluorescence that's present in
the tissue that comes from
collagen that comes from formalin et
cetera so we take that as a first step
before we actually stain the sample
so that's um background or af removal or
a
subtraction we call it sometimes and
that is a source of inherent signal
within the sample
now when you have a staining protocol
and now we go through a very rigorous
process of of validating our antibodies
and we try to eliminate those
markers that produce non-specific
staining but and
sometimes either because of the sample
quality or maybe the
antibody doesn't perform quite as well
as you would expect
you may see an unspecific meaning in the
background and sometimes the example is
sticky
there's a lot of blood vessels for
example and there can be what we call
non-specific state now that is something
that you
have to look out for really at the point
of antibody validation and hopefully
not include an antibody that has a
non-specific
performance characteristics but for the
uh inherent fluorescence
that can be subtracted from your image
prior to the staining step
and that increases your signal uh to
background um
ratio so hopefully that answers the
question and i'm happy to
answer anything else you have in that
regard
next question
i i'm happy to take the next one here
please go ahead all right one of the
questions here um
is what is the difference between noise
and background
so i'll take that again i think that's
related to my last
question and you have our last answer
rather so you have a background that's
inherent
to the sample the fluorescence that
comes from the formula from the
type of tissue lung tissue can have a
lot of um
background uh signal due to the collagen
and other connective tissue
components and then noise comes from the
noise within the system the technical
variation
and it can also be related and
to the non-specificity of some
antibodies as well so
it's sort of a blend of information or
data that you don't actually want
to have or reduce as much as possible
for your final
results that you generate
perfect so actually can you hear me now
yes i found
sorry about that folks um
not quite sure what happened there
uh so i have some questions and first
one
is for for fiona what have you been able
to learn
about the tissue micro environment
through this methodology
um so paul that's a great question um
it's been a
big learning process over over many
years first of all again you need the
antibodies
to reflect the biology that's in the
tumor and
micro environment but the immune
response is one that we've seen
to be particularly profound and very
hugely from patient
to patients so you see in some patients
a very dense
uh surrounding of the tumor with immune
cells and different functionality
different cell states different
political proliferative states
and then in others you have patients you
don't see any anything at all or
very little so that to me has always
just been so interesting and it relates
so much to
um t-cell therapy and uh you know the
prospects there for how it might be
applied to
solid tumors and immunotherapies in
general so i think that's an area that
really is
you know i've got a long way to go in
terms of really understanding
great thank you approach this is a
question for you what if my target is
not on the list of
validated antibodies can i still use
cell dive
sure thanks paul absolutely you can
within
the cell dive software there is a
step-by-step
detailed protocol that will guide you in
characterizing
um the antibody of your choosing to see
you know do you get the kind of binding
that you need do you have the
sensitivity the specificity that you
need
certainly there is a step-by-step
protocol and that is part of
you know we deliberately designed this
to be as open a system as possible
to give researchers full flexibility to
use the antibodies of that choice of
their
choice so that is absolutely supported
thank you very much and uh uh fiona this
is a question for you
the question is my understanding is that
you deactivate the floor for
between rounds but the antibodies will
remain bound to the epitopes
will the antibodies from subsequent
staining rounds cross react
i guess it's another question does the
order of staining make a difference as
well right so
um part of the process yes you do the
antibodies
do remain bound to the recovery and
activate the fluorophore
so part of our process is twofold one we
directly label the antibodies
um we have a first step uh
primary secondary steps which can we
sort of leave those
uh slots open so that we if an antibody
doesn't conjugate well for example
um then we have the option of putting in
their primary secondary in the first
round so there of course you have to be
very careful
with cross reactivity because uh the
secondary is of course you need to have
different species
and you need to make sure that the first
second round doesn't bind
back to the other uh antibodies that are
maybe from the same species
for the subsequent rounds then we use
the um
directly labeled antibodies and that
cross reactivity
isn't an issue at that point we already
have a front blocking step
and then we're just using monophthong um
generally monoclonals but also
polytunnels in some cases
and um we from prominently used a mix of
rabbit anything
really that has been you know made it
all the way through our antibody
validation process
um and they're directly labeled so we're
not using the um
secondary antibodies at that point and
just another
another answer to that question could
you ask about sequence so
importantly two things one the primary
secondary
they go up front you don't mix
the species the second thing is the
epitope sensitivity to the inactivation
protocol so we test all of our
antibodies in the epitopes prior to
during the validation process to confirm
that they are not
damaged by the oxidation process it's
fundamentally an
oxidation process and um by which the
dye
is is inactivated and so if there is an
epitope effect
which we find in about 10 so we
validated about 400 or more antibodies
today
so roughly about 10 percent you do see a
a decrease in signal you can either
try another antibody a different epithel
or
put that antibody earlier on in the
sequence
um so those are the two main
considerations for
the sequence um and then otherwise we
find most of our
but all the other antibodies perform
very well and
they are repeatable and they are can be
placed in the sequence
um wherever you need to position them
great thank you very much we have a
question here
pertaining um has it have you tried or
has anyone tried applying this
methodology to 3d culture models
to better understand culture models
um yeah great question um in fact we
were doing some work recently on this
and in fact we haven't gone so far is to
apply it to the intact 3d structure uh
we have sections we fixed and sectioned
um these samples and that seems to work
fine it works very well we um have
tested in cell culture systems as well
as tissue samples so
our at least our direct experiences on
the fixation and the sectioning of 3d
now there are groups at the nih for
example who are
using clearing methods for 3d and doing
a different type of multiplexing so it
is possible
and it depends on what kind of question
you're asking whether you want to go
until 2d and and then do the same in
that way
or if you want to do 3d then you want to
go into a more comfortable co-based
approach
great um one of the questions we have
pertains to an earlier comment that i
made so i'll be glad to answer it
it has to do with the difference between
noise and background
to me noise is a systematic error in
measurement and has to do
both with uh it just has to do primarily
with statistics
and how you measure something that's
randomly fluctuating
and the certainty that you can have in
those fluctuations
and the closer that those fluctuations
are to the background
to the zero cut off the less certain you
could be in your measurement
whereas background is a systematic
offset that can be caused either by
non-specificity
of an antibody or could be caused by
light leakage or other things
autofluorescence other aspects that will
increase the
the signal not specific to the
measurement i want to make
and so uh signal to noise or the amount
of signal that you have relative to
those random fluctuations
generally determines how what your
detection levels will be
so how low you can go in in mass and
still be able to detect it
whereas specificity my ability to
specifically measure what i'm interested
in
has to often to do with the background
intensity
uh around other things that cause
intensity not related to my signal
itself
so i'll take uh one more
thing there's a question about how is
the inactivation of the dye molecule
um transpire what goes on there that
deactivates the the fluorescence
molecule
so where we use a mild uh oxidation
method
that and we use cyanine dyes signing
backbones
side eyes and lexidize um are compatible
with this
oxidation process and um that removes
uh oxidizes destructs the dye within
15 minutes or so so it's um pretty quick
and
mild on the tissue great
thank you very much well i see that our
time is just about
up and so we're gonna uh i'm just gonna
ask if there's any final comments that
either brought you
or fiona would like to make um
otherwise any questions that we weren't
able to get to will follow up with email
and make them available to the entire
audience uh
thank you again speakers for your time
today and for your important research
and your work in this matter
i would also like to thank lab roots for
sponsoring this
and helping out with this presentation
and again if you have any questions
we'll try to pick them up
through email and thank you and have a
wonderful day
goodbye thank you